Speaking of this extraordinary book that I've been reading
and I will forever have the chart
that Dr. Perry put in the book, as far as-
The the upside down triangle?
The upside down triangle.
what you guys talk about as far as the impression
that children are left with at such an earlier age
than I think was spoken about in at least my growing up.
I think even into almost having kids,
I feel like everybody kind of went,
they won't notice when they're young.
And I did not understand why that was the notion.
It didn't seem right, it didn't feel right,
but I wanted to believe it
because that's what so many people had said.
Here's the bottom line
that really was the hugest epiphany for me.
all these years, I've done multiple shows where people say
exactly what you just said, Drew.
Oh, they won't remember.
Yes, I'm in an abusive relationship.
And as soon as, you know, the kids are young,
when they get older, I'm gonna move,
I'm gonna get out of the relationship.
The most damage is done from zero to two months
'cause that's the time when the brain
is taking in everything.
And anybody who's ever had children,
you all know this because you get to watch that whole
language socialization process.
How did they learn the word dada?
How did they learn mama?
How did they learn spoon?
How did they learn?
So as they're taking in all of that
when the brain is the most open and receptive,
they're also taking in all the other stuff.
That changed everything for me,
in terms of how people are raising their kids
and how we see that what you do in front
of the youngest children matters.
You know, I have a question, which is that,
when I was born, my dad, he had split with my mom.
And I just didn't know him, he was very abusive,
He would come around, he would trash the house.
He was scary.
And you know, there are a lot of people
and you share a story of what happened
the first night that you stayed with your mom in Milwaukee.
And for...
people who have had a parent,
one or two that did not want to be in their child's lives
for whatever their reasons were, which is valid to them,
very hard for a child to understand.
What do you talk through with yourself
or other people who have had that kind of start
to their lives, who deal with that kind of trauma?
You talk about the eyes
and the being wanted and the being set up right.
What happens when you're not?
So here's the good news about all of this,
because all of us have had things
to happen to us in our lives
that caused us to feel unwanted
and not important.
Everybody has at some point in your life,
even if you come from the best of circumstances.
It is possible to take your post-traumatic pain
and turn that into post-traumatic power
and post-traumatic wisdom.
I know this for sure that whatever has happened to you
can also be for you
if you allow it to be.
The thing that has healed me the most
is taking the pain that I endured, suffered,
survived as a child and turning that inside out.
So that is why I created my school
specifically looking for girls who are just like me,
who came from poor backgrounds,
who came from dysfunctional backgrounds,
who many times felt unwanted, unloved,
how do I create an environment for them?
How do I give back?
This is how you save yourself,
how do I give back that which I was not given?
And when you can do that,
you begin to fill the hole inside yourself.
That giving back has become really what my legacy is.
And I will share this with you
that I was sitting with Maya Angelou
after I'd come back from the opening of my school.
And I said, "Oh, this is gonna be,
the school, this is gonna be my greatest legacy.
I mean, these girls, this is what my life was for."
And she said, "You have no idea what your legacy will be."
And I said, "Oh, no, no, no, no, Maya,
you she should have been there,
I'm telling you, it's gonna be the school."
And she said, "I said you have no idea
what your legacy will be.
Your legacy is every life you touch,
your legacy isn't your name on a school
or any other building, your legacy is every life you touch."
So I say this to you, Drew Barrymore,
your legacy, this is what Maya said to me.
Everybody who's ever watched a show
and decided I'm gonna go back to school.
I'm gonna go on a diet.
I'm gonna treat myself better.
I'm gonna leave an abusive relationship.
Every life that you have touched
that has experienced your voice
and the power of your platform, that is your legacy.
(audience cheers)
And that is why in Oprah, we trust.
And I just wanna say also that you said,
"Here's the good news."
That to me is one of the most positive and powerful ways
in which to engage people's minds and hearts
because it is so hopeful.
(upbeat bright music)